es ist eine frage der fitness ist eine
frage der übung eigentlich ist es eine
frage der zahl mich mit meinen ist eine
komödie die in der besten tradition
könnte man sagen des britischen humors
steht nicht mehr du selbst ich weiß
nicht mal ob du mich noch lebst du
triffst dich mit einem man jetzt
wirklich kann ich dich befriedigt er ist
ein mann in mittleren jahren in einer
stadt in england dem namen wir nicht
erfahren
von beruf ist er buchhalter am main am
bass und er ist mit seinem beruf
offensichtlich nicht mehr ganz zufrieden
sind bereits buchhalter 300 jahren rund
um dieser inneren leere oder was immer
sie ist zu begegnen geht er jeden abend
schwimmen eines tages bei markt
allerdings dass nicht alle nur so
monoton wie er da die bahnen ziehen
trifft auf eine gruppe von männern die
etwas auf den ersten blick sehr
seltsames machen eine art wasserballett
regel nummer eins wie man redet über den
schwimmclub pass ins becken gilt bleibt
dem becken männer sind komisch
sie sehen ihr das britische männer und
es kommt was naheliegt ehrlich
schließlich dieser gruppe an und damit
haben wir es mit einem kabel zu tun von
männlichen synchronschwimmen die
schließlich sogar dazu überreden lassen
an einer konkurrenz in mailand
teilzunehmen beziehungsweise dafür zu
trainieren hat auch auf nächsten monat
nach mailand mailand
da ist die weltmeisterschaft ein
absolutes namen von dieser rotmilan wir
es einmal sehr lustig heißt erzählt im
wesentlichen der film swimming widmen
von oliver parker ist nicht irgendein
club
es ist eine idee ein prozess um die
sinnlosigkeit des lebens gegen das was
uns geworden
alle die typen die die das kabel
ausmachen sind auf ihre weise als schräg
oder interessant haben probleme die zum
zu allgemeinen komik teil tragen
[Musik]
dieses sollte ich mir das ansehen weil
ich damit mache ich möchte wirklich dass
du stolz auf mich bist auf was wirst du
mit männern schwimmst und aus dieser
dynamik mit sehr vielen fein gesetzten
pointen mit einem nicht übertriebenen
grotesken humor entwickelt sich
schwimmen widmen zu einer sehr sehr
guten unterhaltungs komödie ohne höhere
ansprüche aber immer mit einem niveau
und in einer qualität dass man den film
jederzeit empfehlen kann für zwei
kurzweilige stunden die dann doch auf
die zentralen themen des lebens nämlich
auf ein gelungenes leben verweisen
[Musik]
[Applaus]